I have diverse educational background
from engineering to MBA and then cyber
security in simply learn after every
certification from Simply learned
Newton's mobile for me same happened
when I took post graduation program in
cyber security from Simply which is
associated with MIT and the
certification of cyber security has
really helped me to get a job in TCS
with 50 percent of salary hey I'm piyush
patnaik I am from Hyderabad Telangana I
have done my engineering in 2013. after
that I have worked in Hindustan
petroleum limited as an internet then I
have worked for Dr Reddy's
Pharmaceuticals I work for asteroids
Pharmaceuticals have worked for Loop in
India after then when I have thought to
upgrade myself and join cyber security
program in simply I have been associated
with simple learn from 2018. I have done
lean Six Sigma Green lean management and
some of the courses and At Last I have
done cyber security course in simply lab
and the certification was a field
beneficial experience of working in so
many companies and the certification of
cyber security has really helped me to
get a job in TCS which the 50 percent of
salary Hank I found the postmetal to be
high quality and the instructions were
very knowledgeable and very helpful I
found the instructions are declaring it
out very soon come out I get time ever
from my work I watch movies and I watch
sports otherwise I keep learning new
skills whenever I want to take a new
course I know where to take it from it's
simple